we begin with an update to a shooting
involving police on the east side of
town a portion of lamb near kerry is
shut down
as detectives are investigating good
afternoon thank you so much for joining
us on this monday at four o'clock i'm
kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas let's head
right out to madison kimbrough live from
the scene madison what can you tell us
[Music]
yes this incident happened just after
noon today on the intersections of lamb
and kerry now this is what we know so
far police got a call of a man
walking through a desert area with a
knife once officers arrived on scene
they found that the man was bleeding
from the neck and the hands
while the officer told the man to drop
the knife the man refused and made
advances towards the officer
that's when the officer shot the man
the mail went down and the officer
immediately summoned for medical
attention
medical arrived and transported the mail
to an unto a nearby hospital
now the man is in critical condition and
police have closed down
this intersection no word on when it
will be open yet
this marks the third officer involved
shooting of this year
of course we will keep you updated as
more information comes through
as you can see behind me it's pretty
backed up here right on lamb boulevard
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now